[Musique]
je me dépêche n'importe comment je fais
plus vite possible et puis on mangera
je possédais un institut en ville et une
de mes meilleures amies a fait une très
très forte et passionnante nerveuse et
adulte à être Internet
chaque jour j'allais la voir
ne sachant pas trop quoi faire pour ne
pas trop parler de sa situation à ces
critique
je passais mon temps soit à la maquiller
soit à lui proposer des soins et je me
suis aperçue que sa compagne de chambre
qui était une personne tout à fait
prostrée s'occupait de ce que nous
faisions elle ne m'avait jamais dit
bonjour elle ne s'intéressait absolument
pas à mon ami et pourtant un jour elle
est venue vers moi et m'a dit simplement
et moi j'ai donc été voir Monsieur Ashe
qui a bien voulu me donner ses pavillons
pour tenter cette expérience qui était
la première en France
[Musique]
pendant le Vinatier on me regarde un
petit peu avec des yeux ronds en se
demandant ce qu'une esthéticienne venait
faire dans un tel milieu
j'ai eu aussi des petits colibettes
droites et gauche mais enfin peut-être
un petit peu pour cela j'ai voulu tenter
l'expérience jusqu'au bout
au bout de deux ans vraiment nous avions
des résultats tellement positifs que
d'autres médecins
chefs m'ont demandé de m'occuper de leur
pavillon c'est ainsi que j'ai eu deux
trois quatre cinq médecins qui m'ont
demandé de m'occuper de leur pavillon
que du reste à qui j'avais expliqué
l'expérience et qui ont voulu également
la tenter
devant cet état de choses je me suis
posée à un problème assez épineux pour
moi à savoir qu'il fallait ou m'occuper
de mon institut ou de m'occuper de mes
malades
très intéressé par la psychiatrie
j'ai décidé de voir mon institut et à me
consacrer entièrement malade
[Musique]
les soins de ces techniques ne sont pas
entièrement gratuits c'est à dire que
les médecins ont jugé utile de faire un
prix symbolique
la malade a tendance à ce qu'on lui
apporte tout tandis que là elle fait un
effort et c'est valorisant pour elle du
fait qu'elle est la cliente et qu'elle
est elle se croit à l'Institut
[Musique]
la première chose qui m'a surtout
horrifiée en arrivant à l'hôpital était
l'hypertrichose chez les personnes âgées
j'entends par hyper très cause
du duvet non pas superflu mais vraiment
épouvantable sur certaines personnes
et donc il y a donc fallu en face des
épilations et des épilations à la cire
sur certaines personnes elles étaient
conscientes et très très heureuses de se
retrouver avec un visage lisse et normal
sur d'autres n'a été que un soin
d'hygiène parce que vraiment c'était
vraiment trop la lettre sale et sur
d'autres la famille a demandé par la
suite qu'on le fasse vu l'aspect
agréable que leur visage représentait
après une telle chose
[Musique]
voilà elle est là énormément de grand
parce que elle s'est quand même heurté à
beaucoup de difficultés et même dans
l'esthétique au début on en souriait
alors que moi pas du tout je l'ai
apprécié et surtout ce qu'il faut dire
elle a eu énormément de volonté et elle
a fait ça bénévolement
alors que maintenant dans notre
professeur d'esthétique on donne ça
comme une porte de sortie à toutes ces
élèves mais il faut quand même voir
qu'il faut avoir des connaissances
médicales et voyez-vous madame lascar
avec tous ces soucis de femmes mariées
de mère de famille a quand même passé un
examen d'infirmière psychiatrique et
même elle a fait du secourisme justement
pour être à même de comprendre les
malades vous avez assisté à ces
difficultés aussi on ensoleillait parce
que élégant
[Musique]
les femmes ou des hommes qui font de la
dépression nerveuse mais qui frisent un
petit peu pas complètement la folie
alors on dit pour soigner des folles il
faut être pas tourné bien rond soi-même
pour pouvoir les comprendre
une malade qui décide d'aller voir
l'esthéticienne qu'est-ce que ça
représente pour vous
ça représente
déjà une victoire avant même qu'elle
aille chez l'esthéticienne parce que
c'est déjà une manière de dire je veux
vivre je veux être quelqu'un je veux
sortir de
du refus
c'est accepter d'être
c'est déjà un pas et ce pas
l'esthéticienne avec le travail conjoint
les infirmières
l'accentuera et puis ce qui est
important aussi c'est de parler autour
de l'esthétique autour de d'un masque de
beauté autour d'une meilleure allure
d'une meilleure apparence
et par la même la malade
devient quelqu'un qui peut se présenter
à l'extérieur être quelqu'un à
l'extérieur et
enclencher un nouveau un nouveau vouloir
vivre nouvelle capacité d'être
[Musique]
à tous vêtements
dans mon dossier et je montre à mon fils
pour le faire rire
elle est complètement folle pour appeler
quand je pleurais quand on éteint dessus
la table de soins que je voulais pas que
je voulais même pas vous laver c'était
ça
[Musique]
je suis coquette c'est pour ça que j'ai
des amoureux
les malades mentales sont souvent dans
un état de prostration de s'intéresse
plus alors personne à leur corps alors
esthétique et que par conséquent dès
qu'on peut réveiller ce côté-là
on a des chances si vous voulez de voir
la malade s'épanouir à nouveau si on
regardait devant la glace
se considérer comme une personne humaine
alors que parfois c'était c'était pas le
cas alors je crois que c'est dans cet
esprit là que nous avons fait cette
tentative et d'une façon générale on
peut dire que c'était vraiment réussi
que nous avons de
des résultats heureux il faut remettre
voir ce qu'elle malade à l'hôpital
psychiatrique un pour voir comment
madame lascar peut agir dessus or ce
malade il faut pas oublier qu'il est
écartelé qu'il est dépersonnaliste et
qui perd tout ce qui peut lui être
propre
il a il a juste un lit il a un placard
au grand maximum et
il a plus rien d'autre en réalité je dis
pas en théorie mais en réalité l'hôpital
c'est fait pour autre chose que pour
soigner les malades c'est
c'est pourquoi
[Musique]
c'est le lieu de réclusion c'est fait
pour que
pour le mettre de côté et qui qui
ressemble à tout le monde
fait longtemps que vous n'avez pas une
massage comme ça
oui
ça fait combien de temps
[Musique]
on sait que
par exemple au cours d'une dépression il
y a une façon de se coiffer une façon de
s'habiller qui peut-être significative
que
l'aspect extérieur l'aspect esthétique
de
malade enfin peut-être surtout chez la
femme c'est un enfant une façon de
masquer certains aspects de sa personne
en même temps une certaine façon de les
exprimer je pense qu'il y a des
indications des comptes indications je
crois qu'on se précipite un petit peu
trop sur les indications et qu'on fait
comme ça des et qu'on prend comme ça des
décisions un petit peu rapides souvent
chez des malades qui qui chez qui ça
risque de douter leur dise mon phobie
quoi enfin
de ne pas se reconnaître
je crois qu'il faut être assez tempéré
je pense que
il y a des contre-indications il y a
même des contre-indications majeures en
particulier chez les schizophrène je
pense que quand même ça crée quand même
un certain climats quand la maladie on
va l'esthéticienne elle est beaucoup
plus détendue et je pense qu'elle peut
dire davantage de choses que une
infirmière enfin qu'un autre moment par
exemple elle est beaucoup plus détendue
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup plus de
choses qui peuvent passer dans un
service où il y a par exemple 90 malades
une malade soignée c'est vraiment une
goutte d'eau alors moi je crois que
cette goutte d'eau
est utile parce que tout ce qui n'avance
pas rétrograde dans mon idée et que déjà
quand même un premier pas
[Musique]